okay so I gave you that idea in question
one let's have a look at question two
and let's actually do this one together
okay
work through it with me
it says a park is in the shape of a
right-angled triangle maybe you want to
draw along with me you've got your right
angle triangle there they've
conveniently provided a couple of
measurements already on there so we
might as well also include them this is
the park it's base is five meters longer
than its perpendicular height now please
note you could have got H and H plus
five just from that sentence right but
they've tried to give you a bit of an
extra nudge by putting it on the diagram
if the area of the park is seven hundred
square meters find the dimensions okay
let's do it I'm up to step one
do I need to introduce any pruning rules
in this case no it's done they've
already sort of held my hand through
that awkward so next I want to model
this okay this situation this
information the question I can write an
equation that it capsule eights all of
that what is the area of this triangle
what's the area of a triangle in general
it's half base times height 1/2 base
times height do you agree that's the
area of the triangle right there okay
but I know what the area of the triangle
is they tell me it's going to be equal
to 700 so this thing here that's my
model okay and I'm going to use it to
solve the question I'll have to step
three and I want to suggest what I could
do to this to make it a bit easier to
work with
yeah area what you reckon
okay so h plus 5 on 2 i can divide both
sides by H that's a perfectly valid
mathematical operation however I'm going
to point out to all of you remembering
where I'm going I would argue that
actually makes things worse I get
further from a solution not closer let
me help you understand why what kind of
problems are these that we're looking at
quadratics right so what I want to get
to it is something which makes it really
clear that this is a quadratic and what
you've done is actually taking further
away it's not wrong it just is going
somewhere else okay here's what I'm
gonna suggest
I don't like fractions they make things
hard to deal with so how do i what will
I do to both sides to get rid of this
fraction if I multiply both sides by 2
if I divide it by 1/2 which is both
lemma 2 I'll get this that looks like
1,400 is that okay yeah now I said under
step 3 I've got these strategies my
first one is factorized and this is a
this is factorized so dot my done why
isn't that fact factorized like
factorizing is what you want how come
this is not what you want what's missing
how look at this equation here we need
the right-hand side to be zero we need
all of the numbers that are relevant all
to be on one side so I'm gonna do that I
can expand this at the same time that
gives me H squared plus 5 H and then I'm
going to subtract like so ok now 1,400 I
don't know the factors of 1400 okay so
if there's no shame in it grab your
calculator and try and divide by some
things we're looking for a pair of
numbers that multiplies to negative 14
hundred let's make an importer for that
and adds to 5 so once we negative one's
gonna be positive
what do you got
1400 divided by 20 is 17 right 70 no
yeah it is 70s that's no good 28 28 and
50 28 and 50 40 and 35 40 and 35 does
that are they far enough apart 40 and 35
will do it one of those negative which
one 35 is the negative how did I know
that it was 35 that was negative when I
when I add them together I need to get
plus 5 yes so the negative 1 must be
smaller okay I factorize successfully
what do I do this just stop for a minute
put your hands down
which busines well Lizzie give me a
focus
let's try again you've gotten all the
way to this point you factorized look
back over at our algorithm that we've
built over here to help us what was the
point of factorizing so I could find H
this solution there are two values of H
that flow out of this don't pick up men
yet I just want you to follow with me
have a look negative 40 or 35 okay now
don't read this yet I still what should
our focus I've got enough space that
I'll be able to do this I can say I've
got two solutions out of this but one
doesn't make sense
you don't just pretend it doesn't exist
you deal with it you say but have a look
at what H represents it's a length so
therefore it has to be positive right in
fact I would encourage you to even write
that H is greater than zero it's a
length sometimes H can be negative right
if H is say a temperature temperatures
can be negative if H will say a time
time can be negative if times zero is
like midday then time negative one is
like 11:00 a.m. something
that so negative answers can be
meaningful sometimes you have to check
the meaning or a question it depends on
how you define your number if this is
like height above sea level then yes
negatives would be below sea level okay
you can pick up your head now I'm always
at the end I've checked the meaning I've
noticed that out of my two solutions let
me start again I've got a solution I've
checked what it means and for that
reason I have excluded one of the
answers so H equals 35 only I'm gonna
encourage you to put that word only
there because it indicates you've
thought about the two solutions and
you've discarded one of them for a
reason so that's why you only end up
with one of them now the last thing is
how I answered the question just by
putting that number there sometimes you
might get lucky they just want that
number have all the court the question
asks okay so dimensions is more than
just one number I've got the height but
I also need the in this case probably
just the base will do right when you
think about the dimensions of a
two-dimensional object all you actually
need for the case of this triangle is
its height and its base you already know
it's a running triangle you can't supply
the hypotenuse if you want but that's
extra information that doesn't add
anything okay so I think I've got just
enough space over here I'm gonna say
therefore and these questions aren't
sentences so I encourage you to provide
your answers also in sentences the
dimensions are 35 meters
it says height it says height so I'm
just gonna use the word height the
ranges are 35 meters high and what's the
other one
40 meters 40 meters for the base .
that's a bad al fixin up there you go so
you can see if pruning rules aren't
given to you you justify them you can
make them what if you like X Y Zed
anything though it does make sense to
choose letters that make sense based on
what they've given you the question
that's why they call it H for height we
modeled it by creating this equation
that might be the hardest part right
there because once you come up with that
the rest of it just kind of falls out
use whatever appropriate strategy works
and have a look at your answer and make
sure it makes sense in the context of
the question